the blame game is now in full swing
after the hilariously embarrassing
failure of Republicans and Donald Trump
to get that Obamacare repeal and
replacement pass they've been promising
that for a very long time I don't mean
seven years Trump for a year and a half
or longer Donald Trump is blaming not
only Paul Ryan but also Democrats wait a
second yeah Donald Trump told The
Washington Post Robert Costa that
Democrats are to blame saying quote we
couldn't get one democratic vote and we
were a little bit shy very little but it
was still a little bit shy so we pulled
it of course they didn't get democratic
votes but the real issue is they didn't
even get all of the Republican votes
they have a Republican majority in the
House and Senate it wouldn't have passed
the house based merely on Republican
opposition it wouldn't pass the Senate
based merely on Republican opposition
here's a quote as you know this is
Donald Trump to Robert Costa from the
Washington Post as you know I've been
saying for years that the best thing is
to let Obamacare explode and then go
make a deal with the Democrats and have
one unified deal and they will come to
us we won't have to come to them after
Obamacare explodes the beauty is that
they own Obamacare so when it explodes
they come to us and we make one
beautiful deal for the people question
one I already mentioned why do you even
need Democrats when you have a majority
in the house second question is why
didn't Republicans get behind him part
of it is because they said it was too
similar to Obamacare it was two left
part of it is that some of them realized
Pat that it was going to be bad for
their constituents if they passed this
and then they go back to their
congressional district they will have to
deal with exploding premiums people who
can no longer afford or otherwise lose
health care Trump told kosta they were
within five to 12 votes of passage in
the house the reality is there were
probably three dozen Republican members
of Congress who were not going to vote
for it this is not the Democrats fault
well a big part of it was because the
freedom caucus was also against this
bill because they just wanted a clean
repeal to get rid of Obamacare and
replace it with nothing else yeah so it
shows you that politics make strange
bedfellows because the people in support
of this bill were all the mainstream
republic
deal against it Democrats
middle-of-the-road Republicans and also
the freedom caucus when you have such
widespread opposition to something you
have to start considering it might be a
really bad idea for your constituents
and I hope that most voters will realize
who is to blame here and what is going
on I'm not confident I'm saying I hope
but I'm not hugely confident today's
show made possible in part by casper
mattresses as many of you know i've been
sleeping on a Casper mattress since
moving to Boston over a year ago and
it's fantastic the Casper is an
obsessively engineered mattress at a
price that I think you'll find
shockingly fair it is supportive memory
phone which creates a really great sleep
surface with the right amount of sync
and the right amount of bounce and you
can try a Casper mattress for 100 nights
risk-free in your own home if you don't
love it they'll pick it up and refund
you everything I think I've mentioned
this also when you think about the size
of a mattress you see this mattress
delivered in a Casper box you look at
the box and the instant reaction is
there's no way that the mattress is in
the box but through an amazing feat of
physics and science the mattress is
folded up and compressed into the box
and it expands as soon as you open the
box in a way that is entertaining to
watch so you'll be entertained before
you actually even sleep on the mattress
but sleeping on the mattress was also
really great free shipping and returns
to the US and Canada over 20,000 reviews
and an average of 4.8 stars it's one of
the Internet's favorite mattresses you
can get 50 bucks towards any mattress
purchase by visiting casper calm /
pakman and using offer code Pakman
that's PA ke ma n terms and conditions
apply casper calm / Pakman use the
coupon code PA que ma n